Fortunately, the answer is the third one.
What you need to do to prove an upper bound are on the hardest of a problem is
if you can find an algorithm for example that solves the problem--provably solves the problem
and provably into the fourth time, then--well, we don't know if a faster algorithm exists
but we know it's at least solvable in end to the fourth.
So the big O or Θ that we get from that is exactly the upper bound.
These sorts of things are really helpful to do--well, actually so this first one is really helpful to do,
running on a bunch of inputs, look at the shape of the graph.
I can give you a lot of insight that might help you decide what you want to prove about the algorithm,
but this itself doesn't really prove anything.
Running something on all possible inputs is impossible, unless it's a problem where the inputs
are constrained, so there's only a few possible inputs.
Generally, the running time scales with the size of the input and it can scale arbitrarily large.
And yeah, actually studying algorithms and how to analyze it is exactly what we're doing in this class